I'm gonna chip and put that piercing in
the unborn baby so when it comes out it
goes I'm bored
go Volkswagen right in this situation
there was a child who was abducted in a
car right wait what was it
covered the river oh it was a carjacking
and there was a two-year-old boy that
was still inside the car at the time
right it's messy yeah why did they leave
the kid in the car when they ran into
the grocery store orgasms from whatever
it was but in this carjacking while the
boys were still uh while the boys was
still inside Volkswagen has a thing
called Carnet service right which is
basically
um like an OnStar or something it's like
it's a tracking system um but the thing
is it's subscription based and they
didn't pay the bill and since they
didn't have the subscription service
they couldn't locate the car and the
police weren't able to locate this is
one of those OnStar commercial [__] like
you'd never [__] know you need it
unless you need it except for the fact
except for the fact that all of those uh
security features or or tracking systems
do have a bypass for legal so it's
already on there yeah yeah like police
always are supposed to have a bypass oh
so actually so they probably just got
their card information first made sure
that the payment went through and then
that's what they should they should have
what if they call how to say I'm sorry
they didn't pay for the cyst that we
can't give it up well that's exactly
what actually happened in this situation
because for whatever reason some sort of
either technical difficulty or something
on the back end that didn't make sense
they could not access it because of the
subscription service and the police can
get through too so the only way to do it
was the detective had to pay 150 wow to
turn it back on but in in doing this
this whole process took so long they
were actually able to locate and find
the car and uh save the boy before the
subscription even came back on because
they have to call the [__] the thing
and then it's outsourced so you gotta
talk to an Indian man exactly it's third
party controlled right
and the Indian man's like I understand
your frustration I must talk to my
supervisor and I appreciate your
patience but I must talk to my
supervisor and you know you know those
papers rustling because the dialogue
doesn't match I kidnapping kidnapping
kidnapping kidnapping
there's a kid that's sleeping so um they
said quote unfortunately there was a
delay as Volkswagen Carnet would not
track the vehicle with the abducted
child until they received payment to
reactivate the tracking device in the
stolen voltage true that if they're
contacting that person their hands are
tied they can't do anything it is true I
guess there's still definitely be uh the
the fact that again every single one of
those
um tracking systems is supposed to have
a law enforcement bypass like they yeah
it should it makes sense Volkswagen even
says like [__] OnStar but whatever
that one is where you're like I got in
the crash help me you know like you
gotta call the [__] and then they're
like man you didn't pay your
subscription We're Not Gonna help I
think we should have some empathy for
the carjacker because he just wanted to
steal the car he didn't want to do
kidnapping he didn't want to steal his
baby it's not his fault can you imagine
he's in the car and he's like oh [__]
you crying little [__] oh [__] man you
hungry also like why there's so much
technology for your car and there's
nothing for kids
but we're putting a lot of expectations
on a company that you know fudged their
emissions data oh yeah that's right so
like that's right you know we we
shouldn't we shouldn't like blame
Volkswagen just chip the kid man forget
the car yeah trip the kids
I plan on chipping kids really oh my
whole family I think I should get one
everybody we're gonna be chipped and
then anyone any one of us can locate our
wherever we're going dude I'm chipping
my kid too make sure it starts with 666.
just so that way would you chip would
you chip 166. I probably would if they
had like a like a safe version they got
that now dude subdermal you guys we're
all already [__] we have Nano I don't
know why no one believes that we all
have Nanobots in our I want a big
nanobot though I want a big one one that
blinks around your ankle most Asian guys
do
I want one that's ass that's uh like
linked up with an app where I can track
people I won't want this linked to my
ass replace a tooth with one yeah dude
put it in their ears do they for dogs
the little chip that they have it's just
in their ears so they could probably
just inject it into our ear it'll just
stay there no my dogs is under her right
right underneath her skin
my baby's gonna have one of those
piercings in the middle oh yeah as you
should he's a Tracker and stylish pretty
metal dude yeah I don't believe it'll
also shock them if you press a button
yeah don't do the bracelets don't do
things that can be you know thrown away
taken off you know you just got it yeah
I'm gonna chip and put that piercing in
the unborn baby so when it comes out it
goes I'm bored baby stupid
you know the things if you if you chip
your kids though you have to think about
this during the rebellious stages
they're going to want to get rid of it
so I would chip like put 20 of them in
their bodies so they don't know so they
don't know which ones activate and also
if they if they get crazy go I'm gonna
cut my hand off you can never track me
well you're gonna take 20 different
parts of their box that's a crazy kid
all right get out there just throwing it
out there you can chip your kid that's
at least your problem and then you can
remote control them too big that means
you're a bad parent
by the time they're a teen though I'd
probably let them loose
I think is when they're cute like a
toddler you want to keep them and you
feel hurt if they run away but by the
time they're 12 people I'm just like
like you want them to leave go I don't
give a [__] live you're gonna D chip
them I mean if they want to
[__] you Dad I'm running away and then
you can't find me and I'm like I never
wanted to so it's like go ahead son
there's 19 more
and then let them go and grow go and
grow go do your thing go go away some
books run along children Nick and
Charlie that is pretty cool that cars
even have that like that is pretty
awesome
when it works when it works I mean
because like how many cars don't have
that that's pretty all of our classic
cars though it's like that's already
like a major luxury I think but what if
it gets into the point too where like
it's like electric cars where all the
governments can just shut it down if
they want to and you can leave
quarantine time guys didn't they do that
in the documentary uh iRobot yeah that
documentary was real yeah where they
stopped all the cars from going well
Smith is a great documentary it is I
think the worst backlash of everything
being electronic is just the fact that
you'll be forced to pay for a lot more
[__] and and it monopolizes like where
you can go to like get certain things
for your car that's the part that I
think is worse well that's where the
wall thing comes in so like if we do a
wall around the country you know a lot
of people support that's cool but then
once cities and counties start going hey
we don't want these people coming in
whoever these people are let's start
fencing our city in and like Walling
Community yeah and then if everyone has
an electric car they can just rather
than checking ID you could just prevent
cars from enter ring your area and then
we have the safest city we've had zero
crime in the last 14 months why because
we have this system where these cars
can't enter unless you pay these taxes
or you live in this area that's
interesting we got our 1980s
plow right through these homes
try to keep my van out of that place you
know what's funny is so this sounds like
when cars came into the scene and people
with horses are like laughing they're
like they can't even think this is
stupid right that's kind of how I feel
about the gas Community versus the
electric car Community with electric car
Community they're like oh what if it
[__] turns on you dude yeah or like
there's an electromagnetic pulse and
then yeah like the documentary War of
the Worlds where Tom Cruise's um minivan
worked because it had no electronics
yeah but everyone else's cars didn't
work dude you know a lot of
documentaries I'm single man like while
you have sex I watch documentaries hey
don't say that about me okay I don't
have sex it takes it as an offense
you know
you're sitting next to them there's no
denial too it's not even like no no no
no no no there's no difference if he
liked his [__] style everyone said no
and then he's the only one that was
quiet so I know what that means yeah he
loves it yeah
other videos guys so we can stay on
track who cares dude no this is the
video yeah I would buy your sex tape
I wouldn't buy it I would buy stock in
it because I know that shit's gonna sell
I want to get another ground floor I bet
you that's his style he has a ground
floor Style
on the bottom style from the side style
upside down different music genres
hip-hop country rap like all that I'm
like I don't do upside down Styles I
don't do that can we not make this about
you Anthony for once yeah so Volkswagen
emits a serious breach they said that
there was a serious breach of its
process for working with law enforcement
in the Lake County incident the company
uses a third party vendor like Ryan said
to provide the Carnet service quote
Volkswagen has a procedure in place with
a third party provider for Carnet
Support Services involving emergency
requests from law enforcement they have
executed this process successfully in
previous incidents unfortunately in this
instance there was a serious breach of
the process we were addressing the
situation with the parties involved so I
think even more just like in that
conversation about like all electric
vehicles and boring cars be able to come
in blah because they have control of
different things there's also the what
happens when they lose control lab is
when somebody hacks it you know what I'm
saying it's like you can't have that
system that's supposed to work that way
and not take into account it goes both
ways accidents there's just moments that
don't work out you know but they say
that about like when they build dams of
bridges this will never break and it
breaks like two seasons later it rains
like it's never rained before and then
the bridge are damn great we weren't
ready for that yeah have you guys heard
that guy uh Mike Baker he's like a CIA
agent he was on Joe Rogan a couple times
I've seen that guy so that guy he talks
about how like you know sometimes you
hear about like diplomats or whatever
like they're in that black SUV and then
they end up falling off the side of the
road they die or whatever he goes I'm
not saying like that it's on start but
he's like things can happen with that
and that's how assassinations could
happen but I'm not saying that that's
how it happens yeah so it goes both ways
yeah
he's like when he's like when people
want you dead they're never gonna make
it look like someone killed you yeah
because they're Pros yeah they're Pros
it's gonna look like it will happen to
yourself yeah there's a Chinese
documentary about that where the
Assassin his specialty is making it look
like it naturally happened what's it
called I forgot something Chinese
documentary about assassin about how
they it makes it look natural but like
he would do things like where he would
put like he would make ice like on he
would freeze like water and they would
slip and then like they'll hit something
this is Mortal Kombat are you talking
about Sub-Zero and then he'll do things
like like Elevator Shaft like the
elevator will fall but it's like natural
it's X-Men yeah natural elevator fall I
didn't know Scorpio was Japanese
I was like that's that's the way to do
it because that's how Pros would do it
like if we were doing we'd be like okay
let's blow his car up yeah we'll go
that's exactly this is how what happened
yeah somebody shot I hate you man
like what how did you find her I shot
him
[Music]